[Music]
Frank when did you get a inkling that
there was something amiss last night
with the Knicks in Derrick Rose well
well you know Jeff hornacek at first
told the media before the game that
everyone was available except for the
one looky who's viscous and then right
before tip-off they announced that
Derrick Rose is not going to play and
that he's not with the team and I think
what you just said about Phil jacks and
is one hundred percent right you know so
by set by seven o'clock the Knicks knew
that he wasn't there Derrick Rose wasn't
in the building and by the time the game
ends Phil Jackson should be the one that
has to get up there and explain to the
media what the situation is you know
Jeff hornacek every day has to address
why'd you guys why'd you guys lose why
did you play this guy watch your call
time out here what's going on with this
player he has to answer enough question
this is something that he shouldn't have
to deal with and I think it shows poor
leadership on Phil Jackson's part I
think it just speaks to the
accountability in the franchise it all
starts at the top and you have Phil
doesn't want to be you know kind of held
responsible for what's going on her
clothes is a no-show doesn't even feel
obligated to call anybody even Carmelo
we all like you know the third time he's
been kicked out of the game and it
looked like Carmela was kind of bailing
out on his teammates late in the third
quarter of the game ok do we know the
story about Derrick Rose was there a
family emergency that he was flying back
to chicago did he fly back to Chicago it
at that with that uh you know couple of
people said he is in Chicago I don't
know the reason why he was there but I
would say this if we were a family
emergency I can't imagine that whatever
it is whether it's with his son his bomb
his brother whoever whatever the
situation is I just can't imagine how he
can take what would it mount to what 30
seconds to text someone in the nuclear
innovation just to say I got something
on I'm not going to be able to make it
to the game tonight I can't imagine that
you can't take 30 seconds out of your
day that's really leads me to believe
that it's not that and made me system
pouting maybe he's just upset with how
things are unfolding in New York if you
go back to last season in Chicago he
showed up on ebay and he was talking
about his free agency
which was new years down the road you
know that's what a focus of his and
maybe he's thinking that the way things
are going on in New York this could
impact his free agency maybe he's in a
little bit of a mental funk right now
but I would also think that let's face
it the money being thrown around nation
be a feisty if he has an ok season which
he's been having he's having a better
than okay see he's gonna make pretty
good money so I don't know why he'd be
that worried about it free agency might
not get Mike Conley money 150 million
but he's probably gonna get paid because
everyone gets paid me but ok so did this
have anything to do he's been benched
the last couple of games in the fourth
quarter yes against the walkie he was
benched and that was based on
performance and the Knicks actually came
back and won the game you know with Ron
Baker at their place you know they came
back from 18 points down now the game on
Saturday night in Indiana they were
getting crushed and then he sat in the
bush because they would they were down
by 29 points in that game so that's more
of a you know what let's just call off
the dogs will get ready for our game
Monday against a wall and so the one
again on Saturday you would think that
he would be able to understand that on
Friday how can he be upset that came
back and won the game without so 15
hours later Frank we don't know anything
right now I'm sure by now I would have
to think that the Knicks must know
something maybe they're gonna get there
trying to get their story straight right
now but it was clear the thing to the
Knicks definitely wanted it out there
that they didn't know what the situation
was with Derrick Rose where he was or
why he didn't show up for the game and
then that's what makes me bleed I just
don't think it would be a family [ __ ]
doesn't make me sense because it too
easy to explain away I can't make the
game tied I got something going on it's
it's it's it's an emergency and then you
move on from there he didn't even give
them the heads up on that which leads me
to believe that him my guess is that
it's just it Betty's pally that he's
upset with something that's going on
team related maybe I'm going to be wrong
about that but i would guess by his
accent he's been an illegal waters a 28
year old man how would you not feel the
obligation to alert your boss that
you're not to show up for work what's
the availability today
uh they practice it news will probably
get them at around one o'clock you know
we've we've had a bunch of uh you know
over the years there's been some
interesting days up there in this
practice so they the one time you know
going all the way back to when latrell
sprewell broke his hand on a boat during
the offseason so there's been some crazy
days I think this one's gonna probably
crack the top ten dam is carmela there
if I know there's the no-trade clause
which was silly to put that in there but
it i was falling bread crumbs with
Carmelo just didn't feel like you know
he'd be saying to Phil Jackson in that
cryptic way but it is Carmelo there for
the long haul do you think he ends his
career as a nick doesn't seem like
anybody ever ends it is an echo I was I
would say no to that one I do think
he'll outlast Phil Jackson I don't think
that Carmelo whatever did Phil Jackson
the satisfaction of outlasting him in
New York I also think too if Carmelo
were going to leave now he loves it in
new york number i'm sure doesn't like
the situation right now but there's very
few teams that you could trade them to a
because of his contract and also because
where he would agree to go to I think he
would agree to go to the Clippers yes
Chris Paul it's LA at the house there
doc rivers are contending team and then
in the east I really think the only team
that he would consider would be the
Cleveland Cavaliers LeBron and once
again a very good chance to get to a
final and win have fun today Frank we
appreciate you joining us hey Dad every
time I turn on TV it's either you or
Jennifer Garner in a commercial i think
you have herpes I think you're more
commercials and jesus my lord you got a
great agent Dan thank you Frank that's a
frank honest soul he's got great here
New York Daily News reporter the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you